und jetzt das heute journal
ihre Mannschaft hat Geschichte
geschrieben mit Marokko hat es erstmals
einen afrikanisches Land ins
WM-Halbfinale geschafft und einen Nation
ist im Glückstaumel
Spanien rausgekickt Portugal rausgekickt
und Ronaldo zum Weinen gebracht was für
ein Turnier für die Marokkaner guten
Abend zum heute journal das inzwischen
nicht nur Marokko sondern die ganze
arabische weltkopf steht ist natürlich
auch für den Gastgeber Katar ein
gewaltiger Glücksfall dieser Glanz wird
an einem anderen Spielort allerdings
gerade wieder zunichte gemacht
ausgerechnet Katar soll hinter dem
korruptions-skandal im Europäischen
Parlament stehen fünf Verdächtige
darunter die stellvertretende
Parlamentspräsidentin sind weiterhin
Polizeigewahrsam sollten sich
entsprechende Berichte bestätigen lief
die Bestechung ganz klassisch ab mit
Geldsäcken
das EU-Parlament legt die Latte gerne
hoch bloß keine Kompromisse jetzt am
Jahresende bei Klima Energie und
Rechtsstaat da treffe es sich schlecht
sollte eine Abgeordnete die Latte reißen
im November hielt die Griechen Eva Kylie
eine Rede die aufhorchen ließ
wie der Sport ein Land verbessern kann
aber hier rufen einige noch immer dazu
auf die Katara zu diskriminieren und sie
beschuldigen jeden der mit ihnen spricht
der Korruption
die Rednerin ist eine Sozialdemokratin
eine von 14 vizepräsident:innen sie
sprach in Katar mit dem Arbeitsminister
und ja Korruption ist der Vorwurf gegen
sie
belgische Stadt sein Welte nahmen Kylie
und vier weitere Personen deshalb
gestern fest Verdacht Geld vom Golf
sollte Gesetze beeinflussen weil es lief
über einen Verein namens fight im Unity
gegen Straflosigkeit beim vorsitzen in
dem ehemaligen Abgeordneten panzeri fand
die Polizei eine halbe Million Euro
Bargeld gekauft der reden davon
berichten belgische Medien gelaufen ist
es unfassbar also wenn sich diese
Vorwürfe erhärten dann haben wir hier
einen wenn ich den größten
korruptionskandal in der Geschichte des
Europäischen Parlaments das macht mich
tief betroffen beim Bau der Stadien in
Katar wurden Arbeiter Menschen unwürdig
behandelt das Europaparlament wollte das
verurteilen in einer Resolution in der
Debatte sprach Eva Kylie gegen eine noch
schärfere Kritik und drängte dazu auch
Fraktionskollegen die müssen sich nun
erklären ich habe die Rede nicht gehört
ich habe ihre Einlassung in der Fraktion
gehört die war schon so dass man
aufhorchen konnte weil das ist eine sehr
ungewöhnliche Position die sie da
vertreten hat und auch nicht eine die
die Fraktion mit Mehrheit vertreten hat
und auch nicht die für die wir
abgestimmt haben so kam die Resolution
durch die Verschärfung nicht unklar noch
ob das auf den Einfluss zurückging
[Musik]
den Verdacht muss man sich noch mal vor
Augen führen wenn er zutrifft
Europaparlamentarier lassen sich kaufen
damit sie Kritik an
Menschenrechtsverletzungen
entgegenwirken da passt es ja dass heute
Tag der Menschenrechte ist in Erinnerung
an den 10 dezember 1948 als die
Generalversammlung der Vereinten
Nationen die Allgemeine Erklärung der
Menschenrechte verabschiedete Orte an
denen diese Rechte nur auf dem Papier
stehen und täglich mit Füßen getreten
werden die gibt es ja leider viele wir
schauen an diesem Tag nach Iran
sie gingen wieder auf die Straßen in
karatsch in Isfahan in tabres in Tera
sie tun es obwohl das Regime mit allen
Mitteln zurückschlägt obwohl es den
Protestierenden mit dem Tod droht obwohl
am Donnerstag mit dem Rapper mochsen
schickerie der erste von ihnen
hingerichtet worden war die Absicht
hinter den Todesurteilen ist denen die
wir Fragen klar doch sie wollen nicht
vor der Kamera reden wir dürfen nur ihre
Stimmen aufnehmen
das Regime tut das um uns Angst zu
machen sagt diese Frau es geht ihnen
nicht darum etwas zu verändern oder mit
dem Volk zusammen zu arbeiten sie werden
nicht nachgeben sie versuchen Angst und
Schrecken zu verbreiten
Mainzer Draht könnte der Nächste sein
der sterben muss weil er an den
regierungskritischen Protesten teilnah
morgen könnte er hingerichtet werden
weil er ein Mitglied der Basic Milizen
angegriffen vom Motorrad gestoßen und
dieses angezündet hatte Gefährdung
öffentlicher Sicherheit und Ordnung
Terrorismus Krieg gegen Gott lautet die
Gründe für das Todesurteil neben Grad
warten angeblich noch rund 20 andere
Todeskandidaten auf ihre Hinrichtung
ich denke die Proteste gehen trotzdem
weiter sagt uns eine andere Frau jeder
Tod ist für die Familie die Hölle selbst
wenn die Leute irgendwann nicht mehr auf
die Straße gehen ist es wie die Glut die
unter der Asche weitergeht
Präsident raisi beschuldigt weiter das
Ausland hinter den Protesten zu stecken
und bezeichnete die Todesurteile als
legitimer Antwort auf die
Ausschreitungen schwer zu sagen ob die
Einschüchterung durch Schnellverfahren
und Hinrichtungen wirkt ob die Zahl
derer die sich auf die Straße trauen
tatsächlich singt steigen aber werden
vermutlich die Wut und die Ablehnung
dieser Rache Politik der Regierung und
so werden sie trotz aller Drohungen und
Gewalt wohl weiter auf die Straße gehen
und mit der Lage der Ukraine geht es bei
dir jetzt weiter Heinz im Osten der
Ukraine gibt es schwere Kämpfe zwischen
russischen und ukrainischen Truppen auch
in anderen Regionen der Ukraine gab es
erneut russische Luft und
Raketenangriffe bei denen immer wieder
auch die
Energieinfrastruktur getroffen wird
Millionen Menschen leiden weiter unter
Kälte und Stromknappheit nach Angaben
der ukrainischen Regierung sind
mittlerweile alle Wärme und
Wasserkraftwerke beschädigt
Menschenrechtler aus Russland der
Ukraine und Belarus sind heute mit dem
Friedensnobelpreis ausgezeichnet worden
bei einer Zeremonie in Norwegens
Hauptstadt Oslo wurde der weltweit
wichtigste politische Preis überreicht
geehrt wurden sie für ihren Einsatz
Machthaber zu kritisieren und
Bürgerrechte zu verteidigen die anderen
Nobelpreise wurden in Stockholm an elf
weitere Preisträger übergeben
in der Dresdner Innenstadt hat es heute
in einem Einkaufszentrum eine
Geiselnahme gegeben die schließlich
durch einen Polizeieinsatz beendet wurde
die beiden Geiseln wurden von der
Polizei äußerlich unverletzt befreit der
Täter kam ums Leben er steht im Verdacht
vor der Geiselnahme seine Mutter getötet
zu haben nach ersten Erkenntnissen soll
der Mann psychisch krank gewesen sein
eine Meldung vom Fußball Torhüter Manuel
Neuer hat sich bei einer Skitour den
rechten Unterschenkel gebrochen und
wurde bereits operiert die aktuelle
Saison ist dadurch für den Kapitän des
FC Bayern München beendet und jetzt die
Lottozahlen dieses samstags die lauten
wie immer ohne Gewähr 3 5 17 23 26 31
Superzahl 8 und weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF
Text auf Seite 556 noch die
Wetteraussichten Morgen zeigt sich im
Norden und im Südwesten die Sonne in den
östlichen Mittelgebirgen und an der
Ostsee schneit es zeitweise leicht minus
vier bis plus 2 Grad zum Wochenbeginn
ändert sich an dieser Temperaturspanne
nichts am Montag schneit es im Nordosten
ab Dienstag Nachmittag von der Schweiz
her im Süden
das war es auch schon von uns geht
gleich weiter mit der zweiten Halbzeit
020 gibt es dann die nächste heute
Express und morgen wieder auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]